foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show it's where we help you win
in your life specifically your money
your work and your relationships the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
I'm Ken Coleman joined by my my comrade
uh Compadre co-worker
uh colleague Confidant I thought
Confidant we got five C's there and he
is the one the only George camel with a
K and uh he's playing her today gotta
gotta got a throat issue going on but
he's not contagious I've had him
screened and I trust you with my life
Ken and uh so we've got a uh you can't
see it here but I put a little Plexiglas
thing here that between us so I think
everything's gonna be all right but he's
playing her but I'm glad you're here pal
I can't miss this no it's my favorite
day of the week with my favorite person
well we have a lot of fun and we're
going to have fun today in helping you
sew let me set the table George is the
money expert I'm the work expert or at
least that's what they tell us we are
and so we say it don't believe it so uh
you know your work issues are always
money related so if I can help you get
unstuck if I can help you pivot uh
because your greatest wealth building
tool is your income and I'm the income
guy for Ramsey Solutions and love
working with George so he's got his uh
Gap Kids uh denim jacket on and gosh
OshKosh B'gosh he's ready I'm trying to
look hip with the young sweatshirt today
okay is it not I don't know what's hip
anymore neither do I why do we we are
not fashionistas well I put that out
there for you to to smack me and you
were very kind today that's a little
pickleball for you I could tell you're
under the weather you can yeah no I
can't but if you want to get you out to
play Pickleball consummate professionals
you you you want to come out and play I
feel like I wouldn't be good at it I'm
not good at ping pong or tennis and it
tells me I'm probably not great at
pickleballs probably true which is why I
want you to come out easy stick to radio
all right good deal Dalton is up next in
Owensboro Kentucky Dalton how can we
help
uh how y'all doing so good I'm running a
little predicament I start an
apprenticeship program
and uh basically how it works is this
job I work for him for two or three
years and then I basically get the
full-time like regular job it's the
state police okay
so my starting income for this
apprenticeship is really low it it's
twenty four thousand is the salary with
the possibility of overtime
as much as I want it's I have to drive
170 miles round trip every day to work
and so with the seller being so low and
uh the drive so far I need the most
economical way to travel by keeping
money in the bank account
is there no option to move closer to
this because it seems like you're going
to be making the move at some point yes
no so when I actually get the uh like
state trooper job I'll be located closer
to home okay I see okay could you uh
where where's home are you renting right
now
uh no I live with my parents right now
so could you go rent somewhere close to
that area for three years
uh no because the I mean that it's a big
city so anywhere near it's going to be a
big portion of my paycheck I don't know
anyone up there to share a house with
could you get some roommates and get on
Facebook and make some connections
uh that's a possibility I'm trying to
stay home because I don't have to
enter lease agreements and I don't know
they're going to survive 170 miles for
three years dude that's I think you got
to choose your heart here that's hard
really hard
all while making minimum wage at this
point I mean
24 Grand are you gonna be able to
survive off of that
yeah I'll be I'll be able to survive
it's just going to be tight so like with
me preferring to stay at home I mean I'm
trying to explore all my options here
okay is there another option to become a
state trooper outside of this
yes but uh this program like guarantees
me a spot to go like in the academy I've
already done on my testing well you have
when I do well you have hours where you
can work a second job
uh possibly but with this position they
as soon as I get certified in this
position they offer all the overtime I
want to work
okay so how long will it take before
you're eligible for overtime
it depends when they can certify me
they're going to send me out of state to
certify me idea of a ballpark Dalton
we're trying to help you out do you have
a ballpark idea
uh hopefully within the next half year I
mean at most okay worst case scenario
all right so here's why I'm digging here
George is what I'm thinking I want to
get George in on here because I want
George to dive in on the budgeting piece
but let's just say it's six months to
get certified uh you may be able to
drive that bite of stick and just keep
driving like that and you're staying at
home keeping your expenses low but once
you get the option for overtime I think
you've got to move there because the
overtime is going to give you much more
income and you do what George is talking
about one or two or three roommates and
and then and then you're okay but this
this you are not going to be able to do
this for three years I'm here to tell
you I'd be shocked if you can put up
with that mentally do you know what the
overtime would pay
uh the overtime would be the time and a
half so the hourly rate comes out to
like 12 so I'd be looking at like 18 an
hour overtime yeah okay I was just
making sure the overtime was worth it
even comparatively to getting a second
or third job that could pay 25 bucks an
hour but it sounds like that's probably
on par and I would rather you get the
experience working overtime so that
you're even more equipped when you step
into this role does overtime include
things like helping big churches get
their people in and out on Sunday is
that something you can do on the side as
well or is that considered overtime
uh no that's not considered over time my
friend then I'd be doing Security in
high school football games uh I tell you
what I know policemen who do the old uh
traffic control
it's extremely lucrative so this is
there's a way for you to make decent
money in that three-year period how old
are you
I'm 18. dude if I was 18 I'd have five
roommates I'd just be doing whatever it
takes yeah but I'm not driving what is
this three and a half hours round trip
every day
uh about uh two and a half hours now
you're a State Trooper you got to drive
the speed limit now
can't be breaking the laws not not a
state trooper yet ah okay so he's cool
she can't be getting tickets when you're
in the program and driving there you
know that's not gonna look good on the
old resume here's the point what I'm
looking at now all right so the car I
drive is a Dodge Charger
and there and back gets about 23 miles a
gallon so I've been doing the math and
all that and that's going to cost me the
same if I get like an electric vehicle
this is not the solution it's not about
the car it's not about the miles moving
you have now if you stay home that will
bring your budget to where all you
really need is gas and insurance at that
point right
yes and so you're going to be able to
make that work on 24 000 and so I'm not
concerned about that now if you move and
you get a few roommates and you got a
little more expenses on your side that's
when the overtime might be needed to
help you make ends meet and still have a
life at 18. but I'll hook you up with
one year of every dollar premium to help
you make a plan for every dollar whether
it's 24 Grand or 36 Grand with overtime
whatever that is you just got to make a
plan now however much you have that
month is how much you can spend and you
have no debt
uh note well the current charger I have
it's 250 a month oh boy let's get rid of
that car payment and that'll help with
your budget my friend so either pay it
off fast or if it's it sounds like it's
more than your half your annual income
so I might sell that thing and get an
old Prius or something that has good gas
mileage that's exactly what I would do I
don't want to take any shots at our good
friends at Dodge but uh the reliability
ratings on the old charger aren't good
you don't want to be putting those miles
on that joint you might look cool but
you'll be broke that's the problem and
it'll break down watch out hey don't
move more calls coming up this is the
Ramsey Show
oh
foreign
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than thirty
four thousand customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsey
that's netsuite.com Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George Campbell the
phone number to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five the
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
with 19 service Brands Nationwide you
can find Reliable help from great
locally owned businesses like air serve
Mr Appliance and dry vent wizard visit
neighborly.com today for help with just
about anything for your home today's
question comes from Charlie in Arizona
currently I work at a call center job
where they constantly change processes
without training us on the new stuff
constant system errors lack of good
communication issues in the company with
vendor communication then managers not
caring and a host of other things that
could and should be fixed all boiling
into longer call times for us which
hurts our performance scores I've made
suggestions laid out Solutions and all
of it ignored all things that could
improve the circumstances for everyone
including boosting business though
without a college degree they ignore me
I have said stuff to co-workers who just
shrug it off as if us having consistent
system problems is just part of the job
but it greatly hurts us do we have to
put up with tons of errors or am I right
to try to improve things am I just
complaining and spoiled or are my
co-workers complacent they seem to
regard me with an air of annoyance wow
yes yes to everything you just said all
of it can be true it can be true
um
if you're being treated with an air of
annoyance from your co-workers it
doesn't mean that you're wrong it just
means that there's too much of whatever
it is you're putting out there and that
you can't change it what's laid out here
is really what we need to focus on
Charlie and that is
you're at a call center
and call centers by Nature are very
formulaic very chaotic a lot of turnover
and they should be run better and I
think that you are uh
you're right to say I think it should be
better it bothers me but you're at a
place now where you it looks to me like
you've hit hit your lid and and what I
mean by the lid is whether Charlie's
right or wrong George whether he's a
little bit too Persnickety uh or
whatever whatever it's it's not a good
fit for him and at some point we got to
go
it's call center and things have gotten
progressively worse and I'm going to
turn into this big giant ball of
resentment if I don't move on you've
tried you've raised your hand it's been
ignored for whatever reason you got to
move on yeah and what I'm saying here
I've never heard of someone who's like I
spent 25 years of my career at the call
center finally retiring this is a good
point it's really not a long-term gig
for most people now here's the good news
your skills will transfer to some great
customer facing roles at Great companies
that don't have this complacency around
them so no you're not spoiled yes you
may be annoying because you constantly
want to make things better when everyone
else is kind of phoning it in pun
intended you see what I did there Ken
yeah I did I see and you did not like it
you picked up what I was putting down
and then you put it back down I you know
I lie I'll laugh out loud if I think
it's worthy if I'm him I'm gonna go
search for a better job with more pay
with a better culture yeah it's that
simple I agree his skills will get him
there that's right John is up next in
Tampa Florida John how can we help
I tell you thanks for taking my call
um I have a question uh kind of a
nearing retirement question
um I am 60 or planning on retiring at
62.
um we've done we've been pretty blessed
I've had a career in Ministry and mental
health and and uh so right now
um we're debt free except we have a
mortgage on our second vacation home we
have a 200 000 mortgage and at this
point I've got enough funds to pay that
off but at that point I would need to
then stop all my retirement savings for
the next two years and uh to build that
back up
um I have a first home
um that's worth about 550 and then the
vacation homes worth about 700. my plan
was when I retired to sell the one home
and pay the mortgage off but you know
with interest rates as high as they are
I'm just trying to see what's the best
financial decision because I'm running
into some obstacles about finding work
after retirement you know from my
current position but it they basically
want to figure out you know what should
I do about this 200 000 do I delay it
for a couple years or do I pay it off
now and let's stop the retirement so I
can build up the liquid savings again
what's your income household uh yeah
household income
um okay I make about a hundred and forty
and my life makes about the same wow so
you're bringing in 280.
yes okay
and how much do you have in retirement
um in in I'll have a I have a pension
she's going to have a pension and we
probably have about
1.3 in just retirement funds oh you guys
are doing great okay if I'm in your
shoes this is a great problem to have
here's what I'm doing you said you want
to retire at 62. that's two years from
now so why don't we throw a hundred 140
000 a year that still gives you 140
Grand to live off of and we knock out
this mortgage with future income without
touching our retirement and still
because right now you have a great
opportunity to do some of the catch-up
contributions for retirement I don't
want you to miss out on sure
so while you have that earned income I
want to be funneling that into
retirement and paying down the house
and the big thing was you know liquid
cash because if we do 62 we have to look
at
um you know things like benefits until
65 and uh you know I think I need to
have that liquid catch but the only way
that I paid the mortar job now I'd have
to stop the retirement stuff and just
save up all that money Where Are You
Gonna live where are you going to live
after you retire
uh we're going to live in the the second
home down in Tampa so we're going to
live there so there's your liquid cash
you do what George says you sell your
primary home right now and there's your
liquid
yeah we need to be we need to be in our
primary for another two years before we
can move into that okay so as soon as
you retire we sell the primary and move
to the rental
yes invest all of that money and you
guys are going to be more than okay at
that point
okay so just kind of stay you know keep
don't use the liquid cash right now to
pay that off how much do you have liquid
uh liquid I have about
230. so why can't you use Liquid cash
and still fund retirement you said you'd
have to pause all retirement if you use
that
white used to just to build that back up
I guess you know but that's what I keep
saying I would just pay it off today man
you'd have 30 grand left over you'd
still have your amazing income to then
funnel into retirement so don't pause
retirement and then a primary home to
sell and there's the liquid is what I'm
getting at
gotcha gotcha how much are you going to
make on the primary home two years from
now uh
um I would say right now it's about
550 so and depending on what the market
does but it's somewhere in that range so
it could be 600 and it's paid for so
outside of fees you'd walk away with a
pretty penny on that so there's the
liquid John that's what I'm trying to
tell you if you do what John George says
you pay off the the vacation home where
you're going to end up living I love
paying this thing off you still got 30
grand and you're not stopping retirement
investment from your actual income and
then when we sell the house we got a
chunk of cash and by the way that
retirement the vacation home you're
gonna free up a payment there that you
can now invest
so you got to think about that too
you're in great shape John but I'm
paying this thing off today I know it
hurts to see that money go because you
guys have worked so hard to get that
savings account up but man having no
debt in the world no payments in the
world if something happens if you can't
work the next two you're still gonna be
okay because you don't know anyone
anything yeah so I love the idea of you
paying that thing off today you will not
regret it my friend
gotcha okay that makes sense I
appreciate it thank you so much yeah
you're in great shape John really good
situation that's impressive huh
vacation home paid for primary home paid
for millions and dollars of the bank it
can happen Ken yeah and they have an
amazing income so let's not you know
forget about that fact or they're making
nice high six figures but for the next
two years let's take advantage of that
yeah I agree I think uh what's going on
there I mean he's he's got it all laid
out but it's like he couldn't see and I
think it's I'm gonna bring it back to is
it just liquidating not completely but
you you take 230 000 and you you take
200 000 out that just feels scary to
people yeah well and there's there's
also this false illusion because he's
got 200 000 on a mortgage right so he
owes the bank two hundred thousand
dollars correct but when you have two
hundred thousand dollars it's hard to
let go of that and see that yeah it's
really a wash so but I'm proud of him
for seeing the light at the end of the
tunnel here and going too we could
retire completely debt free and have so
many options they're gonna have two
pensions 1.3 million in the bank plus
the home primary sale yeah I feel good
about it did he say the uh it's down in
Tampa yeah yeah not the worst place to
be tell you the camels and colemans are
coming we're gonna get Stacy in the car
I don't think we got invited but we're
showing up
listen we go out to go to the four of us
that's true let's just go down to see
John and it's quite a good time just at
least one dinner I think that's fair we
gave him good advice get some fresh
advice was first it's the least he could
do oh we're so excited for you John this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
Coleman joined by my colleague George
camel triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the phone number eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to Danny in Houston Texas Danny how
can we help yes thanks for taking my
call sure
um so I have
um a it's probably a more personal than
than money
situation but obviously everything's
interconnected so I um am having a lot
of health issues that because of where
we live
um it's uh I have a really bad allergies
that lead to really bad asthma
exacerbations and I'm on an off of
steroid then in and out of ERS and I'm
trying all the therapies bless your
heart and
um as a as a physician
in a special a specialty
um I am in a unique area
um I absolutely love what I do I love
the people I work with I don't want to
move
um but my husband being a good man wants
me to be healthy yes and um once what's
best for for me and my health and what
we found from what I can tolerate is the
coasts either one would be better
um and you know of course that higher
cost of living
um a higher tax bracket and for whatever
reason
um in my field uh academic
positions are not paying as well and so
I'm looking at form if we were to move
taking a 50 pay cut and it's it's really
hard for me
to look at that and be like how can I
choose myself
over my family's future
um well let's let's pause there for a
second yeah yeah how how
um what would your household income go
to combined income go from what to what
oh
um okay so it would probably go from
sixes sevens to Fours fives okay so if
I'm hearing you right six to seven
hundred thousand to four to five hundred
thousand okay
um I don't want to minimize in any way
the feelings you're feeling but your
family is not going to be destitute nor
is their future going to be hampered by
by that kind of a drop when you're
making that kind of money after the drop
let's that's assuming that that is going
to be the case and that you can't you
can't increase that but let's just as
just two strangers that you called
George am I right every listener out
there is like I think I could make five
hundred thousand dollars working and we
know you don't mean it that way but most
people heard that and they're like I
think I could scrape by on four to five
hundred thousand I'd find a way and so
I'm I'm not in any way criticizing you
um because a cut is a cut I don't care
how much money you're making and they're
still making sacrifices to be yeah that
will hurt but but I wanted to start
there Danny and then I would also tell
you that if I were your husband and your
husband's already stepped up in a big
way I want you to choose you choosing
you over the income choosing you over
your role with the rest of the family
we'd rather have you than not you
yes yeah and of course those are the
exact same things that are being said I
just I'm like there's no guarantee that
I won't get out there and still have
those same issues
have you been to the coast uh let's say
uh the East Coast have you spent two
weeks there
yeah when we've done different vacations
did it improve when I leave yeah yeah
it is but I've never lived out there so
who knows what would happen during
certain Seasons or illnesses and what is
it that you do
um I I'm a sub-specialist in pulmonary
medicine
so you said you're in the academic side
no it's just that you you are typically
associated with an academic center okay
um too for when you're in that well I
also want to challenge you that there's
there's always going to be a pay cut I
mean I don't know that you've checked
every single role in every area and we
don't know what the next six months hold
as you begin to do more research but I
think it's kind of like you're like uh
it's gonna be less pay it's gonna be
it's gonna be hard I want you to be
optimistic about that I'm gonna get my
health back and as a physician you know
that health is wealth I mean it's
everything
what are you what are you what's holding
you back
I think there's I think you kind of said
it but I think there's I think there's
one thing here that's really holding you
back
we're so close we'll have the the
head off will be good we'll owe nothing
to nobody okay
um how much do you owe on the house
200. okay and yeah and so here's the
thing again I think that's another false
hurdle
um there's a lot of sand on the East
Coast are you aware of this it's kind of
goes all the way I mean you know it's
kind of we got it we got up north goes
all the way down a lot of states and
your specialty pays very well and I just
believe with all the states that have
Sand and Sea Air that there have got to
be some some places where you can move
uh that the income doesn't drop that
much but even if it does you're still
making really good money you sell the
house you're in you may be able to pay
cash for something somewhere else I just
think you're coming up a lot of
limitations and I still think it's
deeper than that I I know I'm digging is
it deeper than this I think it's I think
you really like where you live and I
think this is a massive change for you
that even could
totally change your life because of your
health I think you're reluctant to
change and pull up Roots that's what I
think
I don't think you're wrong we've got
three small kids and it's you know to to
find you know child care and get them
restarted and then you're talking about
probably private schools depending on
the areas that we're looking at so it's
another added expense and it just
changes it changes the whole thing where
you know if you want to be miserable
really comfortable do you want to be
miserable or uncomfortable I mean I have
been for like three years so yeah I've
made it this far they're gonna get their
mom back so let's do that for another 25
30 years now is the easiest time to move
when the kids are little they're not
attached they don't care where they're
at
um I I think this is a I think this is a
do I want to be miserable physically
or do I want to be uncomfortable
emotionally and I think you guys got to
do more research I think you got to
spend more time on this this is a
massive move and I honor what you're
feeling that's what I thought was going
on this you know what this is this is
actually not about paying the house off
this is about the massive amount of
change that this move is going to
require and that everybody understands
yeah I I'm just a very
um regimented everything scheduled
everything's done out and it just feels
like it's a huge mentioned it is Danny
because you know what I bet you your
husband's not am I right he is not I
knew it I knew it because I would be
like yeah let's move let's go I love
change I really do I think change is
great change is exciting but you pretty
much have two types of people in the
world Freaks Like Me and then normal
people like George thank you with a
slight bit of neurosis you know but the
point is is that now that you've
identified what's going on here here's
why I was digging
I love that you listed out new schools
would they have to be private because
we're I like you creating a list
Georgia's actually great at this I'm
gonna laugh this off to you
where she started give her the list that
she would need to make and she begins to
look at different states and different
cities to begin to the point where she
goes okay I can check this off this
office off and even now I know
we can make this change and it's not as
painful as possible yeah there's two
lists for you Danny one is the financial
side so let's start to make a fake
budget using every dollar and go here's
what our life could be in this look up
all the cost of living things look at
private school costs and start to
actually look at facts and you may go oh
we're going to be fine we're still gonna
have plenty of money and then look at
housing so if we looked at this kind of
house here's how quickly we could pay
that offer we could pay cash if we did
this and that will give you some peace
on the financial side on the logistics
side start to write down every single
decision you're going to have to make
and it's going to be overwhelming at
first but I promise it's also going to
be cathartic once you get it on paper
and your husband starts to go cool I'll
take that one I'll take that one you
take that one we'll divvy this up let's
come back and do another budget meeting
another meeting to talk about the future
and that's going to give you so much
peace right now there's so many
variables there's so many unknowns
that's just fear
you got this we're gonna walk with you
hey hold on the line let's get Danny
we've got a checklist and the name of it
escapes you right now but we've got a
great moving checklist that's right that
connects the things that she needs to do
and look at along with our providers
premium as well every dollar premium
let's do that we've got Realtors we've
got accountants we've got tax
Specialists all at ramseysolutions.com
and this checklist will help you walk
and pause living in storage
pods will take care of you my goodness
we've got this Danny don't worry about
it at all this is
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
help you win in your money and your work
and your relationships if you're brand
new to the show first of all I want to
say a big welcome thanks for being with
us so we know we've got some jargon some
language that may need to get used to
you're figuring out which baby step what
is a baby step what is gazelle what does
all that stuff mean we've got a great
little survey for it it takes just a
moment to kind of get caught up it's
called the get started uh button at
ramseysolutions.com just click on get
started and just walk you through a
couple questions
and we'll send you some free resources
and kind of let you know where you are
and get you caught up and it's a really
great help if for those of you that are
diving in deep so thanks again for
joining us triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five Samantha is up in
Columbus Ohio Samantha how can we help
hi nice to meet you nice to meet you I
have
a question I hope it is coherent
um if it's okay I would like to just
throw out some hard numbers for where I
am financially yep George is ready he
loves this
okay so I'm a teacher and
um I bought a car and for some reason I
got on a tangent explaining loans to
second graders and one around yeah I
want to know before we go any further
did they understand anything
one of my kids raises in the sleeper you
should have paid in cash there you go I
was like what that's incredible so I
know it's not ideal we tend to lose
common sense as we get older these kids
get it
I know they do for sure so I have a car
loan of 13
um 372 dollars
um student loans about 26 000.
and then um saved up I have about five
thousand dollars and a high yield
savings account
okay so I was yeah so that's pretty much
where I am I was accepted into
um a grant program requiring me to
commit five years to teaching in an
underserved area
um so with that I'm awarded thirty two
thousand dollars over the course of five
years
the first ten thousand dollars I will
receive in August
so my plan
stopped me in my tracks if I'm veering
off
um yeah so my plan was to take that ten
thousand and then take out the remaining
three thousand for my high yields and
just pay it off in August and just be
done with pay off the car
yes okay I like that plan
okay then that would lead me like back
to the baby stuff one just like about a
thousand dollars in my savings account
um then I'm left with the loans
I am eligible for the public worker
student loan forgiveness program
so if I make 120 payments after 10 years
it's forgiven so I was I don't like that
plan as much you're saying you'd start
that from scratch
yes so I just was wondering what my
course of action should be with tackling
that debt
uh your student loans broken out into a
bunch of smaller student loans
they are okay I'm wondering in your debt
snowball where those would fall
if some of them are lower than your car
loan let's attack those first
so I'm guessing you've got like a five
thousand to six thousand a 10 000 all
kind of in there
yeah they're about like four to six
thousand each okay so let's lay those
out in the debt snowball and you can do
that we'll gift you one year of every
dollar premium and that will help you
list that out do the math for you
okay and that'll get you on the path but
what's your next stipend after that
the next what sorry your next stipend
um I believe it's ten thousand ten
thousand and then it goes down to try to
match
um I guess close this Gap with the
salary and that I think it goes down to
six after that
and then decreases following okay what's
your income
um I will be making pre-tax thirty six
thousand dollars
I think this is the plan I don't like
the public student loan forgiveness one
as much because 10 years of your life to
have to serve at a certain place right
yeah all right so I I you might miss out
on a pay jump to skip to another school
that could pay you double yeah down the
line
do you understand Samantha why we're
saying this like this idea of I'm just
gonna slog through pay these payments
and just let it air out you know this is
just it's keeping you trapped it's not
smart you want to get through this a lot
faster and you can do you understand
what I'm saying okay I do for sure and
and so that's why that's why George is
saying that and that's what's going on
here it's it's it's like you're just
accepting this thing as opposed to
motoring through it powering through it
and that's what we want you to do here
there's also the sun cost fallacy where
you know six years in you go I can't go
to the other job follow me into this
thing by the way George is not emotional
struggling
he's not he's Samantha he's not crying
on your behalf he's his voice is killing
him and he's dying in here so I just
said I want to help Samantha so bad he
wants to help you so bad
you're
so passionate in helping somebody just
allergies it's just
oh
and I was coming so I'm trying to help
you but I can't stop laughing I got the
church Giggles folks that's what's going
on are you okay buddy I'm good I'm good
because if you need me to get up and do
the heimlich right now please do not do
that I go easy
Samantha here's the deal King of the
Heimlich I had to do that on a kid in a
classroom what that's frightening you
did did it work my first year of
teaching it did he looked I looked up
and this kid was white and he had his
hands around his throat this sweet
little boy had brought in mints for
everybody wow and he had a mint stuck in
his throat and yeah and you got it
I got it out and he threw up in front of
the whole class wow I took a dark turn
that's where the trauma starts right
there is when you choke on the air and
everyone for the whole class how sweet
is that
yeah yeah he's never gonna forget that
day all right George let me end on a
high note if we could that would be good
Samantha let's get let's do the debt
snowball smallest to largest regardless
of Interest
and then I would also recommend getting
a second job where you can pay off these
this the rest of the student loans
faster
because even making 36 even having 26
left it's going to feel like a slog so
we've got to get our income up even if
it's outside of teaching maybe tutoring
summer jobs some evenings working retail
or delivery gigs anything to get rid of
this debt but I would not do the
forgiveness program not because I'm mad
about it if you're like a year away I'd
be like all right let's just stick this
out you're here anyways but 10 years of
your life is too long to devote to this
thing for the golden handcuffs
yeah
and I'll be honest with you George when
I heard she when I heard her say this
I've got to go do the research because
when Biden announced that I thought that
that was the forgiveness was for people
who've already done that I'm not saying
she's wrong but I'm gonna dive into that
I'm not sure that that program is for
people that are in it now and they just
get to you just well give us 120
payments and after that we're gonna let
you out that's what I heard her say did
I hear that correct yeah that's the the
pslf program it's been around a long
time this isn't the Biden thing no no
this is different this one's been legit
but it's had miserable success okay
that's what I'm confused incrementally
getting better but still it was like a
half percent success rate to apply and
get through that's what now it's a you
know a three percent success rate so
therein lies my confusion okay I'm glad
I got that cleared I just didn't want to
relying on that and then a lot of people
they have to stick to certain areas
certain jobs certain schools in order to
get it which again limits their career
potential that's what we've been talking
about that she plays that out as it's
just gonna it keeps you tied down uh and
even this ground she said hey I've got
it I know in this underserved area which
means you have lower income that's right
which is great if you're passionate
about working at the underserved area
sure there's nothing wrong with that but
don't do it just because I'm gonna get
this grant or this forgiveness yeah it's
generally not worth it that's exactly
right and I think this is the key here's
here's the message and again I'm not
anti-grant but when you take money and
it has a bunch of conditions you've got
to weigh the conditions versus the
choices you will be able to make and
there's a big difference and I'll tell
you this you know I don't think people
realize this George until they make a
decision like this and they realize oh I
sacrificed some freedom
for this opportunity whereas I can have
opportunity
that doesn't require me to sacrifice
some freedom now sacrifice time
sacrifice money that you pay yourself
great but no conditions and I think
that's what we want people to be careful
of Grants and again grants are nice
loans they all come with conditions yeah
it's tough stuff read the fine print
good stuff all right good hour George
Campbell hey thank you appreciate the
guys behind the booth keeping us going
Austin our fearless leader today thank
you sir thank you America for listening
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show it's where we help you win
in your life specifically your money
your work and your relationships triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the phone number to jump in triple
I'm Ken Coleman I'm joined by George
Campbell playing a little hurt today uh
he's Brave I'm proud of him he's got
more throat code in him than the actual
bottle itself has he's he's sprayed
enough in his mouth the last hour that
I'm not sure you're gonna taste anything
for a month but he's here he's he's
ready to go to take your money questions
I'll help out as well and I'm here to
handle any work related questions
um because it affects your money we want
you to make more money what we also want
you to experience more meaning we want
you to be happy and fulfilled the
largest net worth millionaire study ever
done was done by Ramsey Solutions and 96
of the net worth millionaires
loved their work and that's why I do the
work stuff here at Ramsey Solutions so
we're here for you you ready to go pal
ready he's hydrated let's go to Georgia
in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania home of the
Steelers Jordan what's going on
hey thank you guys for taking the call
here this afternoon you bet what's up um
hey I was just I was reaching out to you
guys um so I'm just kind of learning
about Dave Ramsey here and uh my my
fiance and I are getting married in June
of 2024.
and I'm about a hundred thousand dollars
in debt
um uh car loans and credit cards and IRS
um and I'm just you know I like to be
able to cash flow the wedding and I'm
just kind of determining you know which
direction I should go at like where
should my focus be at this point whether
I should just continue to save money for
the the wedding or you know continue to
um you know just piling money towards my
debt so all right so what's uh let's get
some numbers here okay so what's your
income
uh my average is about 200 000 a year
okay great and uh how much is the
wedding price tag
um I'm budgeting 40 000 and is is the
wife the wife's family the wife to be
her family paying anything is it all you
uh so her
um the my fiance is going to be her
family's been paying about 20 Grands
does that leave you with 20
uh that's correct
forty thousand
I'm sorry honeymoon and okay oh so so
what's your what's your what do you have
to come up with after they put 20 in
uh my again my budget is about 40 000
all together including the honeymoon the
the additional rings and and the wedding
okay so you put in 20 and her family's
putting in 20.
correct how much do you have saved
I have about 25 Grand now all in
everything in in all of your savings you
have 25 Grand
correct okay what's the debt how much
debt again a hundred thousand
hundred thousand I have uh forty
thousand to the IRS
um and then there's about 12 000 on
credit card and about a 45 000 car loan
how much is the car worth
in the last two months it's probably
worth about 50 Grand I'd sell the car
today
right right out of the gate
okay Jordan I know that hurts but think
about this man you could be completely
debt free with a paid for wedding with
an emergency fund 11 months from now
that's where I would want you to be so
you're asking us which one should I do
which should be the priority I think yes
to everything you have the money for the
wedding set aside let's now focus on
debt payoff or use part of that 25 Grand
put 24 towards your debts because you
got to get the IRS off your back that
goes to the very top of your debt
snowballs that goes first okay and if
you get rid of this car and you're
making 200 Grand dude you're gonna
Breeze through this debt pay off this
debt snowball and then still have time
to save up for the wedding yep
now I'm gonna come back to the car
because I heard the doubt in your voice
okay I understand I'm gonna come back to
it
Jordan what's this car what'd you buy
uh it's a Toyota 4Runner no you liked
that 4Runner that's a sick whip all
right all right all right you like it
it's a great car I don't know what sick
whip means that's what kids say is that
what the kids say I'm middle-aged George
uh but here's the deal you can get a
five thousand dollar car
and it'll get you going for just this
maybe is a six month situation maybe a
year your fiance's she's already said
yes you got a ring on you got no one to
impress anymore it doesn't care that's
true I know I'd sell the car that just
listen what's your car payment right now
I'm about ready to throw up I'm sure
what's the car payment on this uh yeah
you probably will about right I thought
it was my the car payment right now is
753 I was gonna get 7.50 again I just
threw up on my mouth I have to swallow
it okay there it is that's disgusting
700 oh my gosh dude what do you do with
that car what do you do with the 700 a
month 750 a month as soon as you pay the
you sell the car what do you do with it
you worked out on the snowball you start
paying stuff off that's a huge chunk of
change my friend over the next 11 months
that's 8 300 that could be back in your
life and yes you're gonna have to go get
a cheap car but you sell for 50. yeah
it's you owe 45 you have Savings in the
bank let's put some of that together
maybe it's a 10 grand ah there you go
that's a 15 grand car doing that with
cash will still put you in a far better
position
by the way Jordan as we're playing this
out I'm trying to sell you on this big
time okay you can flip that car you get
that ten thousand dollar car an eight
thousand dollar car you can flip that
six eight months from now and probably
get most of that back yeah
you see what I'm saying that
appreciation has already happened the
depreciation on that has happened and
and you're you're not driving it a ton
you know what I'm saying so I just want
you to see what we're trying to do is is
free up cash for you the IRS owing the
IRS forty thousand dollars would make me
have high I wouldn't be sleeping tonight
oh my gosh
yeah I from 2019 through 2022
um
I don't care when it's from right
I just haven't bit the bullet and didn't
really want to pay Uncle Sam yeah well
you know what happens when you don't pay
Uncle Sam you go to jail like this isn't
like they're gonna come after this is
unless your wages ruin your life hey
Uncle Sam well how do you look in an
orange jumpsuit
because that's what you're looking at
and that's not really going to happen to
you but the point is why are we even
having an emotion about it I hate taxes
more than anybody I know but I also hate
the idea of jail
[Laughter]
he makes a good point you know what I
mean so hey you're there
so you've got the cash for the wedding
and you got 5 000 extra
you sell the car that knocks out half
your debt right there just selling the
car done
are you IRS will get paid a few months
later leaving you with just the credit
cards you'll still have time to save up
for the wedding and dude eat choose you
want a forerunner or fiance because at
this point your priorities have to be
straight here and she would rather see a
guy who's debt free starting off their
marriage on a great foot rather than a
guy who looks cool in his Forerunner
yeah absolutely and you'll get that
Forerunner back I'm not you're going to
be back there probably two years from
now you're gonna have to be driving an
even nicer 4Runner but you're gonna be
paying cash for it yeah
tell you what George I want the old beat
up 4Runner that I paid 8 000 for when
I'm running from the IRS problem is
though I wrecked that car four runners
hold their value man even an old no
Runner they really do it's insane you
can't even get a 4Runner for eight
thousand it must it have 400 000 miles
on it it's unbelievable they're tanks
what do you call those the Forerunner
what's the make on that oh Toyota there
it is Toyota Toyota
I love when he says that folks I'm
easily entertained this is
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George camel my new
nickname for you is uh gargle McStuffins
that's a new one I've been called a lot
of things and that's not the worst I
just made it up he's in here gargling
the guy's playing Her Today George is a
he's a real stud he's uh he's playing
her she's got the throat issues and he's
gargling in between I just woke up today
I said what would Ken Coleman do he's a
true professional he Powers through yeah
a couple things uh the warm salt water
gargling which you're doing uh the the
hot tea with the honey
Ken is now my PCP unfortunately thanks
again unfortunately you've been talking
all morning so I wanna I wanna get your
take on this I'll set you up uh I've got
an article in my hands this is a uh
CNBC article and uh
this is written uh in in kind of the
first person uh a reporter and I'm just
gonna skip all over that and get to the
reality here over half of Americans
earning
more than a hundred thousand dollars a
year are living paycheck to paycheck
this is according to a recent report by
payments and Lending Club
earning more than a hundred thousand
dollars a year would put you well ahead
of the median American household which
brings in 74 780 dollars
so assuming you're an individual with
dependence at salary would qualify you
as upper class
through three different definitions
but if we skip the whole upper class
middle class all that
we're talking about people
making over a hundred thousand dollars a
year that are leaving paycheck to
paycheck
according to data from the Bureau of
Labor Statistics you'd have to earn
about 129 thousand dollars today to have
the same purchasing power that a salary
of a hundred thousand had just a decade
ago
so how far your dollar goes depends on
cost of living
and George we say things like cost of
living but then that just assumes it's
like well this is just what it is no you
determine your cost of your living just
because you live in one region of the
country or the other doesn't mean that
you have no responsibility or no say in
your cost of living and you were just
telling me something oh which I want to
cite because I think this is a great
example and you said that you were in a
little which I don't know why you do
this but that's not the point you were
in a little uh little tiff if you will
with someone on social media today and
the guy was giving you the business
about how in the world can you say that
you can live in a New York City on a
hundred thousand dollars and your reply
was yeah here I always think of this
Mark Twain quote never argue with an
idiot they will drag you down and beat
you with experience and that is what I
do every time I go in the comments
section I know and uh so this guy we
posted a clip from my YouTube channel
and it was about how people make a
hundred thousand dollars feel broke and
it's because of debt it's because of
their lifestyle and he chirps and going
this guy doesn't understand that there's
areas of the country where you can't
live on a hundred thousand dollars and I
went bro if I didn't have any debt I
could show anyone how to live on 100
Grand in New York City I promise you
that
here's what grinds my gearskin in this
article it says thanks to a combination
of federal state and local taxes along
with Sky High Cost of Living a hundred
thousand dollar salary in New York City
is worth more like thirty five thousand
smart asset found
I'll show you smart asset here's the
deal you can include cost of living and
just take that out of someone's check
um so when it comes down to it let's say
you're effective tax rate effective tax
rate now marginal well you actually
ended up paying even in New York City
was you know 25 30 even 35 that still
leaves you with about six grand
take-home pay
now New York City rent of course it's
going to be really high now if you're a
single young person live with roommates
I live with roommates all the way up
until I was married I know it's not fun
I know you'd rather have a beautiful
Penthouse in New York City on your own
and if you want to own a home you may
not be able to afford a wonderful singly
single family home in the best
neighborhood right now you might have to
get a condo that's 20 minutes further
out but people don't want to make these
sacrifices Ken and they love to complain
about inflation and cost of living and
yes those are astronomically high but I
truly think the answer is debt lifestyle
and lifestyle creep there's no more you
make the more you spend we all think we
can't live without debt well you got to
have a car payment right and these
student loans I mean you can't get rid
of these things well unless you know
what let me just throw something out
there I'm not gonna go t too deep down
this this road but this article mentions
Tennessee where we live I love the state
of Tennessee one of the many reasons I
love state of Tennessee is because they
don't tax us on our income no state
income income tax and I just got to
point this out people griping and
complaining about the cost of living in
New York and they basically say because
Tennessee doesn't tax earned income a
Memphis residence what they pick the
city of Memphis earning a hundred
thousand dollars takes home seventy four
thousand after federal state taxes and
because the city's cost of living is 14
below the national average blah blah
blah blah blah this feels like it's all
this stuff guess what you can move
you can move
and if you and if you move here can I
just say this you should maybe vote like
we vote because that's why we don't have
a state income tax don't go voting to
have an income tax and I'm not I'm not
listen I know people get nervous I'm not
going to get political on one side of
the aisle or other I'm just going to
tell you the facts are the facts you can
move or you can change the way you vote
what are you going to gripe about taxes
there's a pretty clear choice most of
the time so I just get so irritated with
all this cost of living and taxes this a
taxes that well guess what
you have a say in it move and if you
move vote differently and then and then
spin differently there's your three
points George you can't just make it all
about the money you also got to decide
where do I want to live why do I want to
live there what does that mean and if
you want to live there go make some more
money that's the whole point but no they
want you to give them more money and so
that doesn't work that we should just
feel entitled to live in New York City
for fun regardless of our income that's
an insane take sure I'll call Stacy on
the way home today hey babe we're going
to the upper east side of Manhattan
because I want to and and now
everything's just gonna happen and
forget the numbers we just we're gonna
gripe about it the entire time or you
know you just can't Manifest this stuff
it's it's it's mind-boggling I know I'm
getting grumpy but it's just
mind-boggling to me I love grumpy Kent
it's my favorite
folks if you're just joining us George
is not emotional today his voice is
coming and going he doesn't know when
it's coming he doesn't know when it's
going but when you talk for a living
it's just exhausting they don't tell you
that much we have a good time so here's
the deal what we have to understand is
when we started this article we laid out
some data that we have more hundred
thousand dollar in over earners than
ever
that are living paycheck to paycheck
and the reality is is that the more that
we make the more we are tempted to spend
this is The Human Condition and so it
comes back to something that Dave Ramsey
has said for decades it's not about math
it's about the behavior it's the person
in the mirror and and and when we can
get to a point where we go you know what
I'm going to sacrifice I'm going to wait
a little bit
sacrificing waiting ends up winning but
when we don't sacrifice when we don't
wait and we say give me now I want this
now we make decisions and before we know
it we have literally painted ourselves
into a financial corner where then the
only option is massive sacrifice
and massive misery you've heard the
calls on the show well people are going
we got to sell everything we have to
move yeah because we're broke yeah and
then what is our prescription to them
you know we're saying you're not going
to see the inside of a restaurant for
two years unless you work there that's
not fun
but the more we make decisions based on
what we want now versus what we want
long term the more we get ourselves into
trouble and that's what's going on it is
unconscionable to me that a hundred
thousand dollar earner is living
paycheck to paycheck because in America
you can make changes you can change
where you live you can change where you
work you can change how you spend this
idea that I've got to have more money
and I'm griping and complaining going
inflation it's so high and it used to be
this and I shouldn't get ingested my
income based on inflation you're gonna
lose your job
you're gonna lose your job no company
can pay you commensurate to inflation it
is impossible they will go out of
business you don't so asking for
something like that is mind-numbingly
stupid yeah it all comes down to delayed
gratification and here's the thing we
can always look back and go man in the
1950s a hundred thousand dollars that
would turn into twenty thousand you
can't keep looking at the past well
you'd have been broke in the 1950s too
yep that's the problem you gotta look at
reality and go what can we do next
knowing what we know what can we control
we can control where we live how much we
work what our income is that's in our
control
all right folks more throats pray for
George and more of your calls right
around the corner this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
George camel we are here to take your
questions about your money your work and
your relationships the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five eight eight two five five two two
five we go to Kansas City next where
Alexander joins us how can we help
hello there how you guys doing today
we're having a blast what's going on
me and my wife were talking right before
the show started and figured we'd give
you guys a call
I've been working with the company for
the last seven years and at the end of
last month I was laid off I'm the sole
income earner for our family and so
right now we're basically living our
savings and I did get a little bit of a
severance which is nice although I was
one week for my sabbaticals it's not sad
to lose that so sorry about um it's all
good certain things happened in God's
timing how long is your Severance going
to carry you or how long could it carry
you
um so the severance was for 12 weeks
with our savings right now we have about
I think I did the math twenty seven
thousand dollars in savings so should be
able to get us through about a year
however we do have a baby on the way in
October um so got to pay off the rest of
the medical bills and repair for our
Midwife and things like that so I'd
include that in the cost as well okay
and the 27 000 tell me about that what's
the is that your emergency fund
yeah so that was the emergency fund
we've been working on saving that up I
learned about you guys I don't know 12
15 years ago and so uh we tried doing
that and when me and my wife got married
we uh sold my other cars that I had to
pay off our debt and so up to last year
we were debt free okay
um however however our basements uh
started to bow in about five inches so
oh God we had to take a loan on that
because we hadn't saved up uh preparing
for something like that how much is that
is that the only debt you have
that's the only debt we have
um that that debt is about 15 14 15 000
okay
and how much does the 27 000 represent
six months four months five months
uh so if we could if we truly cut down
everything we can make that last
probably uh anywhere from a year to 18
months oh good grief okay well that's
okay and what's your plan for income
so right now working a bunch of
different jobs I actually have a couple
interviews coming out
um I'm listening to some of the
commercials I was actually possibly
going to apply to the Ramsey office so
uh we'll see that but essentially just
applying everywhere I can trying to get
as many interviews as possible and try
to find something here in the near
future okay and you're working while
you're doing that in odd jobs or side
hustles
I haven't currently uh I was looking at
things like uber and other kind of uh
jobs like that however our cars are too
old to qualify for those
um but uh right now what's your I'm
sorry so I've asked you a bunch of
questions what is your question
yeah no worries
and we have the Fourteen thousand
dollars in debt should we wait until I
get a job
um to then use the money and pay that
debt off or should I go ahead and do
that now uh and just basically use that
as a fire to get a job faster yes you
should pay off the debt today get the 14
000 out of your life what is that going
to represent in payments what are you
paying on that 14 000 right now
is 270 right so we just found 270
dollars in our budget per month that's a
good thing you're debt free
and and you still have a decent
emergency fund so what you're doing is
you're just kind of going backwards here
and you're going to go pay it off and
now we're back and you've got the
six-month emergency fund based on the
numbers you told me if you said you
could live on that for a year 27. so so
go ahead and pay it off all right now
you live off the severance
and to be honest with you I wouldn't
even live off the severance if I could
if it were me right now because I had
the severance I put that Severance back
into replenishing that emergency fund
and I would be doing side gigs side
hustles anything I can to just pay the
four walls and try to tighten everything
up until I get another full-time job
that's what I would do George do you
agree or disagree no I'm with that you
know in the baby steps we say you can uh
there's con historic and store mode and
you guys are in both right now you're
going to lay off and a baby on the way
so I want you to stack up as much money
as possible until mom and baby are back
home safe you've got income back but to
Ken's point you guys aren't going to be
totally broke even paying off this debt
you're still gonna have a nice cushion
sounds like you guys can live on very
little and like Ken said I wouldn't wait
to go find that next big job I'd be
doing a bunch of stuff right now in the
meantime to create any income yeah I
mean listen listen two and three jobs
Alexander at least two to try to make up
what you were making what was your
income before
I was about eighty thousand yeah so look
if you can you may not make the same in
a couple of jobs where but I would be
bringing it in and then maybe a little
bit of the severance right that makes up
the difference and we stay on budget and
then the extra Severance goes back into
savings and let's just be conservative
in this season because you're going to
get hired we're still in a very good job
market in this country what were you
doing for your work
yeah so for five years I was in the
learning development phase uh with a
healthcare I.T company and then for the
last two years I was doing change
management
in healthcare I.T
yes okay so you could could you work in
either of those fields right now
uh theoretically yes
um there was a non-compete agreement uh
that goes into effect for a year so
there is some potential restriction
there how do they not cut up a
non-compete when you get laid off
uh you know that that question's great
I'm not even sure it would hold up well
did you get the answer to that yourself
uh so they whenever they had us fill out
the uh agreement to like not Sue here
and get your Severance one of the things
was that basically that not compete is
still in effect
so if you went and applied for a job it
couldn't even be in those fields or it
can't be that role what are the
stipulations of that
yeah so the main stipulation is I cannot
provide the same service to the clients
of that company oh oh that's very
different yeah you can't poach clients
yeah okay okay this doesn't limit you so
uh you see where we're at now like I
said we want you moving forward we want
you being conservative not eating into
that emergency fund other than you are
going to pay off the Fourteen thousand
dollars worth of debt and the good news
is you got three months Severance you
can work and you're gonna be fine you
got it
got it all right my man I appreciate the
call wow I like this worst case if he
does these side gigs let that be enough
to cover their bills to where he's not
dipping into that emergency fund that's
what we yeah we don't want people to use
the emergency for a living now we've got
an article we're gonna we're gonna make
sure in today's show we'll link to on
what to do when you're laid off that I
wrote that it has a lot of different
practical tactical things but here's
what we want people to hear the
emergency fund George our first very
it's not just a list a specific but it's
more of a specific emergency my HVAC
goes out we don't want to live off the
emergency fund now while losing a job
feels like an emergency we don't want to
live off of that well we can go get more
income and so we have to dip into it for
some reason if you're unable to work
there was an injury or something yeah
then use it that but Alexander is very
capable no he's fine so we want to
protect that emergency fund with
everything we got everything we got for
those actual emergencies and to this day
I don't know how you are I try to cash
flow every emergency that I can it hurts
so irritated about it well once you have
a good Financial Foundation you can
generally adjust your budget and go ah
we can skip that this month we can
actually re rearrange the budget in
order to cash flow this and man it it's
amazing how little you use your
emergency fund once you have one yeah
yeah and you tend to have better luck
right when you're broke you tend to have
more bad luck when you have an emergency
fund you tend to have more good luck
because you're able to actually take
care of your stuff and let's not forget
in this situation with Alexander he pays
that debt off today 270 a month right
back to the budget so it's nice that's
nice and then go somewhere without the
Stress and Anxiety if we have this debt
hanging over our head with a baby on the
way while we don't have a job
it's amazing how life storms just that
all kind of hits it once yeah and I will
tell you um you know I come from a a
lower middle class home my dad was a
pastor and he was a church planner and
twice he planted churches the second one
when I was about 12 13. and there just
wasn't much money coming in I mean
that's all support and when you're
getting going and he went and worked
construction man was making really good
money an hour as just doing labor work
on a construction crew it was hot it was
hard that's not what he was but it made
really good money and it took care of
our bills so that there wasn't the
stress of actually focusing on planting
a church taking care of the family and
that's the idea go do whatever you got
to do go work
and make up the difference until you get
stable it's a huge huge relief thanks
for the call Alexander don't move more
of your calls coming up next this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by George camel we're
here for you this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go now to the City of Angels
Los Angeles California Jody is there
Jody how can we help
hi there I'm so glad I got you guys
today thanks for taking my call oh well
thank you
um so we're we're the reason we decided
to call in my husband and I um is we're
a big fan of the Ramsey method uh three
years ago we paid off over 230 000 of
student loan debt wow over about
three years
um they were the worst three years of
Our Lives
they were worth it so you know um we
know that that you guys know what we
should do uh we're caught up we're both
Freelancers we're both in the film and
television industry we're not writers
but we're very much caught up in the
writer's strike oh no
we're not we're not able to find
anything that's kind of relevant and
even you know the few things that we do
find everybody else is looking for work
in the same things everybody else is
scratching around and so we're having a
hard time where this is what I wanted to
get your advice about is you know when
we're applying for jobs uh just to you
know keep moving forward and not have to
you know to protect our emergency fund
like you guys were just talking about
um we're finding that people don't want
to hire us knowing that we're going to
leave in a couple of months um anything
that seems like it would utilize our
skill set or or you know just our
education or just like well you guys are
going to go back to your real life in a
couple of months or you know five months
or six months however long it lasts and
you know clearly we're not afraid of
hard work
um and you know I've been thinking a
cleaning job you know for the past
couple of weeks just to you know have
something to to do during the day that
feels like it's bringing money in but it
really brings in so little money and you
know it just feels like it it's
something that you do and there's not
anything else you can do what do you
guys need to make
I mean we have four months emergency
fund ready for this we kind of knew that
this was coming so nothing is dire
um but you know our operational budget
really isn't about if we don't save
towards our house we're renting right
now if we don't do anything we want to
talk about Bare Bones this just gets you
yeah Bare Bones four thousand seven
hundred dollars we just had a budget
meeting okay great I love that you've
got a bare bones and uh so what do you
guys do what is what is what do you do
what are your husband what does he do
in the world for this current world but
we just somehow still are having a hard
time finding something that utilizes
that yeah and forgive me for the silly
question does that mean that you guys
are actually editing footage
yes yes so what we do is we've been on
some shows um actually the your producer
was like oh do you want to sell me some
of your credits someone tell me and I
was like uh Maybe not maybe my friends
might get worried about me if they're
listening so gotcha yeah yeah we don't
have to do that but we've worked for HBO
we worked for AMC we've worked on some
on some shows that you would definitely
okay so the first thing that comes to
mind is is less LA and more freelance
um we we I have a good friend who
um is is is a pretty he's a pretty
substantive producer works out of his
house in my neighborhood in Franklin
Tennessee
and uh freelance work outside of the
movie and television industry is where I
would be looking and what I mean by that
is you've got you've got people doing
videos all the time social media you've
got companies that need I would be
looking I'd be scouring online for some
freelance video editing because you guys
bring to the table all the skills
necessary to actually just do the video
and this is not stuff that's in La so
you're not scrambling and fighting for
it uh it's remote I'd be looking there
gig work like that where you're doing
any kind of video editing I'd be looking
for that uh remote that's where I would
start
um as it relates to the issue of well
people don't want to hire us I think
you're going to have to do some of that
like you know work I was talking about
like I'm not saying your husband's got
to go do construction but you're looking
for a type of manual labor that pays
really well proud if he's working in a
warehouse and he's making 18 to 20 bucks
an hour slopping boxes again this is not
a step backwards this is just
this is good old-fashioned character we
don't want to touch our emergency fund
and and I'd be looking for Gig work like
that where they don't care you know what
I mean
um
for the introduction they were they were
kind of asking like well can you commit
for a year you know and we were like no
we can't you know even for dog walking
stuff like they just don't want to do
they want to use your commitment
they wanted we've had two different jobs
that we've applied for that wanted a
one-year commitment for taking people's
Bichon freezes outside the P I mean I
don't understand it's crazy you know so
maybe that's our Market in particular
because we do have a lot of people who I
mean even in the best of times are
actors and people who want to have side
hustles maybe they're they're all burnt
out
um but I really do like the idea of just
trying to find something that is purely
remote purely online I know that people
in town could you get connected with
like a wedding videographer and then
they could offload the editing to you
that's interesting yeah I mean uh
wedding videographers I've talked to the
way that they make ends meet is by doing
everything themselves that's right um
but you know there could be someone
who's doing gangbusters but you know
that that takes some hunting for sure I
mean I mean that's my best idea I again
I I don't think that every warehouse job
I don't think that every I don't think
every job needs a one-year commitment
you know and and here's the reality if
if it gets to that point work is work
and if they're ready to hire me and
they're going can you commit for a year
you go I don't know I don't know I'm in
between things right now I don't know if
I can come in or not but I'm ready to
work right now and if that doesn't work
fine but what we've got to do is we've
got to get to the point where that
doesn't matter they're looking for
somebody and we're going to pay you x
amount an hour if you're going to stock
grocery shelves whatever you got to do
what we're trying to do is is one way or
another for the next two three four
months I don't think the strike is going
to stretch six months I don't I don't
think that do you
that's what I think I think you guys got
to figure out 30 days that's what I
think and so I would I would just be
doing whatever and I love the online
model you can't believe somebody y'all's
background you could be maybe teaching
some classes online and you guys are out
there you're not out there schlapping
you know you're in your home you're
doing stuff that you're really good at
how do you transfer the skill and
experience you have to some online jobs
out there where people need talent and
it's just plug and play that's where I
would be starting and again I would be
looking for anything manual labor that
they know it's transient they just need
somebody to come in that's where I would
be looking yeah and I do love Ken's idea
of social media that's such a huge one
is these businesses or entrepreneurs or
creators they're not great at editing
and you guys are experts at that if I
could hire someone like you are you
kidding me at a fraction of your actual
rate I'd be chomping at the bit and so I
would be contacting creators out there
on Instagram and videos you see that
you're saying hey here's where we're at
we're in the rider strike we're looking
for work right now we're willing to cut
you a really good deal to cut you some
really great social media work that can
help you increase your impact what do
you think and I think just getting real
creative and persistent you guys will
get some amazing gigs and that word of
mouth will spread and hopefully be back
to work in no time and one other idea
Jody this is at least worth kicking
around but you know I'm thinking you
think about the East Coast if there's
some production companies in Nashville
or Charlotte North Carolina I'm just
picking cities and they're looking for
some part-time editing I would be
jumping on that they'd hire you in a
second do you know what I mean
right right now we definitely have the
credits we have the resume I mean it
feels crazy sending an editing resume
with you know movies and TV to a
waitressing job they just look at you
and go what is this so they've got to
understand they know how strikes work I
don't think anyone looks down at that
and goes what are you guys doing here
they go wow I really respect that you're
looking to make ends meet and do
whatever it takes I'd be shocked Jody if
there aren't several freelance editing
video editing jobs that are posted from
all across the country that would be a
good short-term fix for you guys that's
what I think
so that's really good that's a really
good place to start I really appreciate
it I hope there's something there I just
gotta believe there are because they
don't want full-time they can't but they
need somebody on a short term level and
you guys could come in and make quick
work of that and as good as you guys are
you might be able to pick up three four
five six jobs over a 30 45 day period
and it's just gravy and it gets you
through that's what that's what I would
try so thanks for trusting us and Colin
I'm sorry you're dealing with this
um here's what I know Jody I just think
it's going to get done a lot sooner than
you think because the industry was
already hurting coming out of covid it
started warming back up and now this
nonsense yeah so I think they're going
to fix it pretty quick it just can't
keep going our hearts go out to all of
you affected by Rider strikes so many
people not just the writers it's so
everyone involved in in making great
film and TV here's a great example as to
why the emergency fund why getting out
of debt matters it allows you to weather
storms like this beautiful work George
Campbell thanks my friend thank you for
hanging out thanks Austin and the crew
thank you America this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
thank you
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the pots
Moving and Storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show where we help you win in
your life specifically your money your
work and your relationships triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
phone number to jump in triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm Ken
Coleman George Campbell is my colleague
and co-host and he is with me this hour
as we take your calls Brendan is up
first in New York City New York Brendan
how can we help good afternoon gentlemen
how are you doing well how are you sir
I'm good so I'm recently married and my
in-laws who are two of the best people
I've ever met in my entire life maybe
besides my wife have a financial advisor
they really like and they've been very
successful with now we had a
conversation with that financial advisor
and it was very basic but of course
being newlyweds we have a timeline to
buy a house key recommended maxing out
our 401ks to use that as a some sort of
tax advantage way to pull out that money
to eventually use that as a down payment
for a house
now I know Dave Ramsey doesn't like when
we touch our 401 case for anything
besides maybe absolute emergencies so in
your opinion said something you would
advise to or something we should steer
clear of in all case
I would run far far away
and bless your in-laws but I am not
using their financial advisor for advice
anymore
yeah okay that's what I thought too and
of course I mean the financial advisor
is incentivized for you to invest with
them so there's already kind of like I
wouldn't take my down payment advice
from from this guy
do you understand why George is saying
run from this why this is a bad idea
I understand our 401ks can be some of
the most lucrative ways we can build
wealth in the long term how it's a good
route to be coming you know as Dave
Ramsey says a millionaire understand the
implications of if we don't repay that
401k loan in a certain time period yes a
horrible horrible that's what that's the
part we we agree that it's a great way
to invest for the future we don't like
using it as a loan it has all kinds of
negative implications and it puts
unnecessary pressure on you why that
route versus another route
uh it's just what he recommended you
know he said there was a good tax
advantage way of doing that no but at
least from my understanding unplugging
the growth of that money while paying
yourself back with interest into the
loan while putting yourself at risk is
just unwise and so if that's how
desperate you are to get into a house we
need to pause and go what is causing all
this why can't we wait another six
months to a year to just save up from
our future income do you guys have any
debt we have no debt and you have a
fully funded emergency fund fully funded
great so what is the down payment goal
and how far are we from it we need about
maybe 200 or 250 000 okay wife and I are
both young uh 22 and 24. we need to
combine 200 000 a little bit over every
single year
okay and do you have anything saved for
the down payment yet uh maybe about a
hundred thousand great so that let's
just look at the facts here you're 150
away how quickly can you save up another
150 Grand with no debt making 200 plus
um maybe another two years maybe I was
gonna say 18 months Max yeah okay
you can live off a hundred and put 100
away
and do that for a year and a half and
you'll get to your goal and you're 22
and 24. that's impressive you guys are
doing so well to be where you are in a
high cost of living area when everyone
says you have to go into debt and your
guys are doing this the right way you'll
be a year and a half older with 250 000
down putting you in a great financial
position and so I would just pause and
go all right we're 18 months away let's
not do stupid with zeros on the End by
doing this 401k loan tax advantage
scheme this financial advisor told us
about
okay makes sense there you go my friend
thank you for the call Let's uh go to
Jake now in Newark New Jersey Jake how
can we help
hey thank you so much for taking my call
sure so I guess a little bit about my
story so I've been with the girls for
about a year and I'm planning on getting
engaged uh in the near future and we've
had a conversation about combining
finances when we're together
uh currently I'm 25 I make about three
times what she makes and
she has about 22 000 outstanding student
loan debt and I guess my question is
uh I guess it's it's just uncomfortable
because I'm not sure or should I be
feeling guilty for not having a problem
combining finances saying hey you know
with the grocery bill and rent and stuff
like that but having some hesitation
when it comes to the remainder of the
student loan debt should you feel guilty
for not wanting to do this when you get
married in other words should you feel
guilty uh because you don't want to pay
off her student loans as her new husband
yeah yeah that's correct so let's say
there's about ten thousand uh
outstanding by the time we get married
uh I mean that's
I again I make three times what she
makes so what do you make understanding
I make 92 000 and she makes 30. okay I
don't think though I don't think the
word is guilt I don't think you should
feel guilt I think you that you should
get over it though because you were
going to come together and when people
aren't on the same page on their
finances Jake it is a very difficult
proposition to have a healthy and
sustained long marriage it's just very
difficult and so you've already
acknowledged that you guys are having
the conversation about combining
finances that's the best thing for your
relationship that's the numbers bear
that out that's not my opinion and I
think at this point I get why you have
this distaste for it but it's it once
you guys walk down the aisle it is our
money
and so that means it is our debt and you
didn't bring it uh you make more than
her none of those things need to be
factors the reality is this is now our
situation and combined we can knock it
out quickly and and move forward in life
and you can't be walking around and
again you're not seeing this in a
negative way but you're calling us and
asking for advice but you don't need to
be thinking a lot about how often how
many how many more times money you make
than her that just needs to start to get
out of this is more on you than it is on
her yeah and so I don't want you
stepping in because truthfully right now
the way you said all this I'm like this
guy's not ready for marriage that's what
I'm doing what happens when she's like
hey I want to add some clothing line
item to the budget you're like whoa not
with my money I make three times as much
and so I don't want that that's going to
cause a lot of resentment and friction
in the marriage and so you got to go
into this going hey I know this isn't
ideal but man we make great money now
combined income of 130 Grand we're gonna
knock out this debt really fast we're
gonna have an emergency fund we're gonna
be able to get to our dreams and the
amount of the the amount of wealth
you're able to build with dual income is
amazing and so look at this like an
awesome blessing there's this amazing
person that you love dearly who's
bringing all this extra income to the
marriage and that we can use to build
wealth
so that's how I look at it
I agree with a lot of what you guys are
saying I think also part of the has not
it's not necessarily hesitation I guess
it's a little uh uncomfortable is that
whatever the remainder is for me I
wouldn't want to say hey let's continue
your payment plan of you know whether
it's 600 a month or whatever it is and
keep assuming the interest I would want
to get that out yeah just knock it out
knock it out knock it out as soon as
you're married have that money saved
knock it out and move on with your new
life new chapter very exciting stuff
you're good man Jake
if you're in you need to be all in my
friend thanks for the call this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman George Campbell joins me this
hour the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to Skye who is on the line in New
Orleans George you ever been to New
Orleans yes I used to live in Mobile so
we'd go there for the weekend trips if
you got distracted I was about ready to
take Skype I do I was you know what I
was thinking a little jambalaya and a
beignet for dessert that's what I was
thinking I got distracted back to Skye
though thanks for the patience guy how
can we help
hi thanks so much for taking my call you
bet what's up
um I'm having a budgeting issue I have
an irregular income and I make an
average about 3 000 a month but
sometimes
like some weeks I'll make 500 some weeks
I'll make a thousand and it's throwing
my budget off like each month I'm trying
to like I I'm I'm just confused what
kind of work do you do
um it's actually a job that I'm trying
to leave it's just a gig job
okay what kind of gig is it
it's it's food delivery okay and you're
saying hey some sometimes it's great the
business is great I'm getting a lot of
gigs and some months it's tough cookies
out there
are you actively looking for something
specific
yes I'm actually looking for a graphic
design job okay
do you have the experience in education
or skill set currently yes
the marketing degree okay great now just
because I I'm I'm interrupting because I
want George to kind of give you advice
on both of these what what range of
income do you think that you will be in
when you land one of those jobs
well I guess around 50 or 60k yeah okay
and what pace are you on right now if
you stayed and I know you're not going
to stay in this food delivery job but
what are you what would you average that
out to right now in that range
oh yeah I didn't understand the question
I know I didn't ask it very well if you
look at what you're doing from a gig
standpoint right now what are you making
per month
on average it's like uh around 3 000 but
sometimes it'll dip a little bit below
that all right so that's a good bit
below a 50 or 60 000 job that's I just
wanted to ask that for George because
you're going to need to transition it's
like you got to figure this out but at
the same time we're hoping we're out of
this gig pretty soon yes
yes yes do you have any debt
like I have a
Financial
instance okay I'm wondering if we find
something more consistent right now I'll
show you I'll walk you through how to do
The Irregular income budget it's pretty
simple but I'm wondering if finding like
a retail job may be more helpful right
now
um I'm just I'm not like I think another
crawler said that I'm like my resume
they don't know how to like apply that
to a retail job it doesn't have to apply
yeah retailers want people who show up
on time who are courteous respectful
good with customers that's all they care
about
okay I didn't uh a while back I had
submitted an application for Whole Foods
but I never did hear back from them yeah
well again let me quick thing on this
you don't want to just submit
applications at this point you want to
be you want to be leveraging
relationships that you have for some
openings and you get a phone call made
on your behalf an email on your behalf
someone there looking for something
right now because the food delivery the
grocery delivery thing right now that's
a pretty decently low bar that you can
replace that income and that's what
George is saying right now while we're
waiting to we're not waiting you're
actively trying to get the graphic
design job
we need to get something that's like
boom they need you in at this Warehouse
or this big box store or whatever and
you're making more and it's consistent
in this season of transition
delivery is not a good transitionary job
unless it's really a hot delivery job
because you're already you're already in
making less than you need to make and
not only making less it's you can't rely
on it it's it's up it's down and that's
really difficult and I just think what
George is saying and I'm putting words
in his mouth because his throat's
killing them it's not necessary right
now like you don't need something that's
up and down in this season we need
something that's stable and consistent
so that we can budget better and we're
much more stable while we're looking for
that better job
I I did like make a contact with a
graphic design guy but he's not a hiring
manager it was just on LinkedIn but I'm
not sure what you're replying back to
and
what do you mean you're not sure what to
reply back to him I just uh I just
complimented him on some of his work but
I don't know how to go from that to say
how to get like a job at your company
yeah well I'll just reach out to him and
say hey do you know of any openings at
your company or other companies I'm
looking to get connected to other
Professionals in this area and if you
know somebody that'd be willing to have
coffee with me or whatever I mean that's
the game and I've got I've got a great
resource for you I'm going to give you a
copy of my best-selling book The
Proximity principle which is going to
walk you through very practically how
you begin to connect with people you
know in that industry and outside the
industry to find things but as far as
the irregular budget I want to get
George in on this because we do need to
get you stable right now yeah and I'm
going to gift you one year of every
dollar premium and here's why there's a
great feature in there called paycheck
planning that lets you lay out your
income for the month and then it'll show
you exactly when you would run out of
money based on your income and based on
your bills and their due dates
okay so that will help you but when it
comes to a regular income you want to
look at this like a prioritized spending
plan and your four walls come first
that's food utilities shelter
Transportation once that gets paid out
you go to the next priority that might
be your insurance bills or fuel fuel in
the car
then you want to go to the next thing
and the next thing until the money runs
out so you may not have money for any of
the little luxuries which it doesn't
sound like you're in that spot anyways
living frivolously here but that allows
you to go if I only have a thousand
bucks this month here's what I'm
covering I know I have to cover my rent
I know I've got to cover the utilities
and if that's all you can cover that
month and a little bit of food that's
okay
okay so that will help you kind of
understand because a lot of people have
a regular income you're not alone in
this and those people need a budget more
than anybody
instead of them saying well I can't do a
budget I have a regular income no you
need a an extra plan for every single
one of those dollars yeah I've been
using spreadsheets and everything but
it's still it's just I don't know it's
just I get like that's having a hard
time sticking to it yeah download the
every dollar app and we'll hook you up
with the premium version that has a
whole bunch of features that will walk
you through this
as long as well as that proximity
principle book I was thinking the same
thing yeah and that Designer knows a
bunch of other designers that's they
know a bunch of other designers yeah Sky
that's the key you want to hang out
here's the proximity principle in a
nutshell in order to do what sky wants
to do she's got to be around people that
are doing it in places where it is
happening so the people are like the one
gentleman you reach out to but we want
to stay off LinkedIn as much as possible
here's what I teach about LinkedIn
linkedin's a great resource okay
it is great for information
that you can then use for a real life
connection do you know what I mean so
you've reached out to and you know what
company it works for you find out do I
know somebody that works over there and
I reach out that way because a lot of
times this stuff on LinkedIn can get
lost and there's a lot of reaching out
and again I think it's a great resource
but I want it for information so that I
can make a deeper real life connection
not just in the app itself and I think
that's that's something to make sure of
but I want to get around other people
that are graphic designers
you know do you have any Social Clubs
that you're a part of or a church or
things like that you'd begin to go hey
do you know anybody and you begin to
find people that are in it you go hey
I've got a marketing degree I'm looking
to get back in the game and uh I'm
looking for some opportunities and the
more I do that eventually opportunities
show up on my doorstep not you trying to
kick the door down and this is a game of
averages right the more I talk to people
in the industry the more of the they
introduce me to more of the right people
they put me in the right places get me
interviews things of that nature online
communities things of that nature in
your area
I'm getting around those people and in
those places and then over time
opportunities are going to show up
they're going to go Sky hey I got an
opportunity for you and it's all because
you stayed present you stayed connected
that's the key not sending out resumes
to companies that don't know you because
then you just get lost you're just a
nameless faceless person and I know
you're much more than that yeah that's
me frustrated
you might as well be playing a lottery
you know and hoping for that as your
retirement strategy that gets
disappointing every Tuesday night when
you don't get your numbers called
frustration so hang on the line we're
going to get you the book and read it
and do exactly what it tells you to do
and I promise you opportunity is going
to knock on your door very soon Skye all
right we got to get out of here for a
couple quick commercials don't move East
George Campbell I'm Ken Coleman this is
the Ramsay show
all right
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by George Campbell
the phone number to jump in is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five always it's good to be in studio
with George and uh we were talking
during the break I posted a little
something on the gram and I reposted it
it was that good oh you repo did you you
shared it I added it to my story because
I was like America needs to hear this
well and so so George wanted to talk
about it so George taken away well you
know we've often pondered what the
Ramsey show is really about yeah because
we've always known it was more than
money money was often a root symptom but
if you really think about what is the
ethos of this place what has Dave been
building for 30 years what is it the
root of the calls and you had this post
that you found somewhere else on
Instagram yeah just saw this little note
and I thought man this is so good and so
I posted it so we can throw it on the
screen if you're watching on YouTube you
can check it out that Ken Coleman there
it is yeah go follow at Ken Coleman
always some great content coming from my
my friend Ken but here's I'll walk you
through it at the top it says out of my
control and it starts to list things the
past the future the result what other
people think of me other people's
opinion and in the middle there's
another Circle that says in my control
and it says my words my thoughts my
response self-awareness how I treat
others and it was just such a simple yet
poignant reminder of the core of what we
talk about on the show whether it's your
career your work your money life your
relationships your mental health it's so
easy to focus on those other things the
past the future
future is all about anxiety pass is all
about shame and guilt the result
something we don't always have control
over what other people think of me
goodness gracious we make a lot of
stupid decisions based on that and other
people's opinion and that comes into
play as we see so many people get
gazelle intents and they have friends
and family members who make fun of them
who question them say it's a bunch of
poppycock and just you know whatever
they want to say and just make fun of
things and so when we get too hung up in
other people's opinions
um what other people say and think then
it gets our eyes off of the prize and
one of the things we've said for a long
time on the show is control the
controllables and this was just a great
little illustration and I just saw it
and I just saw it and I just said that's
good and I need to be reminded that you
need to be ready we are not above this
going see we've mastered these virtues
oh no no we need this constant reminder
yeah and and what's beautiful is that
there is a lot in our control and it may
not feel that way because of inflation
on the cost of living and here's what
man the politicians and the corporations
and when you can just pan back and go no
yes and in spite of that I'm gonna win
anyway so I'm gonna have a great life
anyways and no one is going to control
my destiny that's right but me and so
think about that here's what's in your
control America your words your thoughts
your actions your response the
self-awareness you have and how you
treat others and I think that is a
recipe for Success if we can focus on
that stuff instead of all this other
stuff that's fun to whine about and
complain about but doesn't actually move
us forward so thank you for that great
reminder Ken yeah absolutely thank you
and uh it's a great reminder of myself I
post the stuff that I need to hear that
I need to read and uh if we would get to
a point of just only paying attention to
what we can control you have a lot less
anger a lot less anxiety a lot less poor
financial decisions poor relationship
decisions because we just go you know
what I want to focus on what I can
control good stuff there on your own
race hey uh let's go to George in
Atlantic City New Jersey it's perfect
George I love it George we're glad
you're here talked to George and I
what's going on
hey how's it going I appreciate the call
well answering me yeah I was gonna say
you called us but we'll we're here
what's going on
hey so I just have a question uh I'm
currently running right now I've been
renting for about four years my rent
just went up this month so I'm paying
about 1800 a month okay I'm trying to
figure out should I I do want to buy a
house but I don't like big homes and I
like smaller homes but there are even
smaller homes are extremely expensive
and I don't like I don't have to pay
three hundred thousand dollars for a
three bedroom
so
I'm trying to figure out should I stay
where I'm at for a while trying to save
up a little bit more money and then see
if the market turns around or my other
option was I was thinking of buying a
camper and just living in that for
however long it just save everything I
got and then if I have enough cash to
just I don't know put a big down payment
down or if the market turns around just
go ahead and buy one or all right well
let's get really sure all right so let's
get a quick run on your number so what
was your rent and what did it just go up
to
so it was 1500 a month now it's 1800 all
right so it's gone up and and then what
would a camper cost you that you've got
your eyes on what are you thinking
what's your price range I'm gonna get
one used I don't need one brand new so I
was thinking maybe fourteen fifteen
thousand all right so now we've got to
come out of pocket do you have the
Fourteen and fifteen thousand
I have a
uh the other four I got I I have like
seven cars I can just they're all page
for their cash I can just sell one of my
cars and I can come up with the rest
what are you doing to all these cars
I buy them cheap and I just fix them up
my own so uh hold on a second George I
watch these car flipping shows so I'm a
minor expert on this I'm not okay I
can't even say that with straight face I
just watch a lot armchair expert if
you've got the right cars and you're
fixing these up
and you do this cash you could flip some
of these and get that down payment on a
house pretty quickly am I right or am I
wrong
well you're you're right you're right so
let's just talk about the cars you have
not the one you're driving every day
what are these cars worth
I could probably let my one car I could
probably get like 8 000 for it right now
and I got one more I could probably get
like four thousand for so all right
there's 12. what about the other five
I do drive back and forth to work but
they're the two cars that I I can sell
right now and I can make some money off
of that that are finished that that can
do it and all these are paid for
yes yes they're faithful okay there's 12
George right there yeah what other debt
do you have
just that that's all I have is my my
rent that's it that's all right okay
your rent no debt and you have a
somewhat of an emergency fund with this
ten thousand
yeah okay what is your income
uh I made 1500 to 1400 a week after
taxes
you guys are talking six grand
yes 72 000 a year after taxes so this
1500 1800 it's not killing you so I
wouldn't go uproot your entire life over
300 bucks a month and I wouldn't buy a
camper George Campbell would you it
feels like he's just no throwing cash I
know I I don't I'm not anti-camper but I
feel like most people that call the show
and they're like I'm gonna sell
everything live in the camper it's a
financial hack I'm like number one it's
unsustainable number two it's a
depreciating asset number three I just
think there's better ways to go about
this and that's to use your future
income and have a better quality of life
I have not met people who call on the
show like I lived in a camper for three
years it was the best thing I ever did
they're usually like now you're a single
guy right young guy
no I'm actually I'm I'm married but um
you know I've been I've been going
through this playing with my wife but
she said as long as you got it mapped
out perfectly I'll go with it so she's
just going along for the ride she's a
good woman she's a good woman and I
don't think she wants to learn is she
working as well
no she she stays at home I I take care
of most most of the things okay so you
got some kids
yes too so now we're gonna pack that
whole family in a camper this is
becoming the worst idea terrible idea
yeah I know that's why I needed some
advice it's found and you're saying a
three bedroom is too much you got two
kids man where are you gonna put
everybody
oh yeah I don't know he was gonna put
him in the camper until he called us
that's what he was gonna do George
listen to me you're a good man uh listen
I know your wife's home with the kids
maybe she can pick up a part-time job
you can sell these cars be patient right
now buying a camper is a bad move you're
buying a depreciating asset and it's not
going to help it's going to end up
draining your cash not helping you save
cash and and so I just it's a bad move
bad move yeah I'm gonna be patient let's
get a down payment and if it's a three
hundred thousand dollar three bedroom
let's aim for that let's go for a
15-year fixed rate with a quarter of
your take-home pay going towards that
mortgage that might be a few years buy
yourself some patience but the 300 bucks
truthfully is not enough for me to go
dude sell everything so every car go
live in a camper with a four-person
family that's aggressive yeah yeah not a
good idea you know but love the spirit
he's not scared of work no that's not
that always gives me hope that there's a
solution here and I love that he's I
love he's got some cash cars maybe save
up a little bit of money there fix those
cars up even if he's moving those cars 2
000 here 3 000 there let's get rid of
those you know I know he likes them but
right I'm just sitting around they're
sitting probably paying Insurance on
these things yeah yeah oh that's
interesting stuff thanks for the call
George appreciate it don't move more
calls coming right up this is the Ramsay
show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by George Campbell
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number to jump in our
scripture of the day comes from First
Corinthians 10 31 therefore whether you
eat or drink or whatever you do do all
things for the glory of God our quote
today
uh said but uh appropriate quote Tony
Bennett the Great American crooner dead
at 96 hard to believe
um top five artists for me I know I'm an
old soul I know you'll make fun of that
but uh Tony Bennett in my top five
absolutely loved his sister I love all
the crooners but Tony's up there yeah I
mean I love Frank Sinatra but but I
wasn't alive you know or old enough to
know his work uh personally but Tony
Bennett one of my all-time favorites
also Harry Connick Jr but anyway Tony
Bennett American Legend dead today 96
this quote I think if you have a passion
for what you do then there are no
limitations on how long or how much you
can accomplish I love that he
accomplished a whole lot in those 96
years yes he did all right let's go to
lyrin I hope I'm saying that right in
Los Angeles correct me if I did not get
that right how can we help
hi guys how are you good
did I say your name right
it's pronounced LeRon LeRon all right
I'm Hooked on Phonics usually I'm not at
this moment so now I've got it LeRon is
how we say it how can we help
thank you so much for taking my call I
just have
um I have a question about my current
financial situation I want to know your
opinion on the best next steps that I
should take
so I'm a mortgage broker I'm 29 years
old I've been doing mortgages for about
seven years 2021 I did really well
because the rates were so low they were
in the three percent
I maybe netted about 150 and I was able
to invest into a real estate development
that's gonna net me about 40 000 at the
end of August uh this August so this is
coming up August
and meanwhile while I was doing so well
I did take a business loan to grow my
business once the market turned and the
interest rates went up my business
slowed down substantially and I got into
a large amount of debt so probably
around 200 000 in debt and I only met it
so far this year from The Mortgage
business about 30 000. so I was either
thinking because it's such a regular
income to either file bankruptcy and
close the business and try a new career
that is more more stable or possibly
take that 30 000 that I'm gonna net
in the end of August and and possibly
you know try to to still build my
business
so that's my situation
and what is this business
it's a mortgage brokerage oh so you want
to start your own so you're doing it for
someone else right now when you went hey
I could do this for myself and I'm gonna
go 200 Grand into debt to do it what was
the loan for
no so I've been a mortgage broker I own
my own business for about three and a
half years okay open it up
I was trying to just expand working
capital hire more
telemarketers
and better data to reach more refinances
okay and that has not panned out you
have anyone working for you
I have um I have a contract processor
nobody really on the books so it's just
me I'm a solopreneur but that didn't
really pan out for me okay well
bankruptcy is never and then right Next
Step it's a last ditch effort when they
are coming for you and the cars out of
the drive where they're taking your
house and uh you know Dave Ramsey
famously went through bankruptcy back in
the 80s and it was a last-ditch effort
there was nothing else he could do the
bank called the notes he didn't have
time to flip the properties fast enough
to sell him off and so I don't like this
as like a clean slate file bankruptcy
bankruptcy destroys your life I mean
this is gonna be on your record you go
to try to get a job they're going to
pull your credit report and see that you
just went through this bankruptcy and so
it's going to hurt your financial life
in a big way for a long time and so if
there's anything we can do to avoid this
which generally there is then I'm doing
that it's a lot of a b scenario LeRon
what is that this is this your last
ditch is it only thing you got left or
do you have other moves you can make
so with the irregular income I have a
little hope that I could turn my
business around especially when all my
income goes to payments towards this
debt
so why not just go work for a mortgage
broker
because most mortgage brokers are
commissioned only so it's the same
scenario I would make more money as my
own solopreneur than working for a
company I've Got Friends In The Mortgage
business and they're doing great and so
I don't buy this idea that you can't
make more going to work for someone else
for a while to get on your feet
so because they're going to be feeding
you leads right is that your problem
right now
no I have leads my expense is about 13
000 a month why for Lee because I my
leads cost about seven thousand my rent
for my office costs about three thousand
dude ditch the office stop paying seven
Grand a month for leads and go work
somewhere else yeah but if he does that
I understand that George but he still
has the 230 000 in debt under his
current business agree but if he can go
make a hundred thousand working for
someone else you can clean this debt up
a whole lot faster so shut the business
down it's too expensive yeah I mean your
expenses are gonna compound this debt
issue because you're not making 10 grand
a month
you see what I'm saying it's a simple
math equation you know you're in the
mortgage business you don't want to keep
digging this hole exactly waiting for
something to change so I understand it's
not ideal and you feel like your dreams
are crushed because this business didn't
work out but the last thing you want to
do is have the Sun cause fallacy where
you just keep digging this hole so I
don't think bankruptcy is the option if
you need to go to another career field
right now go do that go make somewhere
you can make six figures and you can
clean up 200 Grand in a few years doing
that but I would not go to bankruptcy
right now yeah I don't think it's it's
not an A B scenario it feels like a get
out of jail free car but it really isn't
um and it has longevity issues it's Its
Own Prison yeah it really is I'm sorry
to hear that LeRon let's go to Brian in
Las Vegas Brian how can we help
hi Kim and George uh thank you so much
for taking my call I'll be quick I'll
try to be quick I am trying to decide
whether to continue saving up to go to
school for physical therapy uh as a
career change but I'm already 50 years
old I've been working 70 80 hours a week
over the last year and a half and I'm
just getting really tired and maybe a
little discouraged just trying to decide
if I'm too old I'm thinking this might
take me another five to eight years and
I just don't know if I can do it just
looking for some maybe some wisdom yeah
well the question becomes at this stage
why Physical Therapy there's a why
behind that work why you're interested
and if we can find something that's
connected to that why that doesn't
require us to go to the physical therapy
school because it's very expensive and I
love that you're working crazy to save
up but there's there's other ways to
help people with physical transformation
or physical healing that don't require
this kind of work and so the question is
was Physical Therapy an idea that you
okay that was kind of cool or is it a
deep seated why like there's there's a
why behind you why you want to help
people this way
um yeah I think I just I do like helping
people and I like the the fact that
you're moving around because I've been
in a job where I sit all day for a long
time and right in the call center
environment and uh just looking for a
change and it would allow that would
accomplish both things I can move around
I can help people yeah
um okay I've got some great news I got
great news Brian I'm going to give you
some resources I'm going to give you the
get clear career assessment that I want
you to take and it's going to allow you
to really dial in on your unique makeup
okay what you're good at what you love
to do and results that motivate you
that'll help because it sounds to me
like you want to be in the people space
you want to work with people and you're
good at working with people is that true
yes okay great so helping them
physically helping them financially
helping them nutritionally helping them
in a variety of ways professionally I
want you to take a little bit of a
breath and can you slow down that crazy
work schedule or you're working all
those hours to try to save up money
yeah I'm I'm kind of resting right now
good I just I got so tired I get it so
stay in a place of rest and I want you
to take the get clear assessment I'm
gonna give you my book from paycheck to
purpose as well they are a combo think
of the assessment as a compass and the
book is a guide up the mountain but I
want you to take some time and really
dive in who are the people I want to
help what problem do they have and what
are the solutions of that problem that I
can get qualified for way less time and
money
and then I'm going to dive into that I
think you're going to be really happy
thank you Brian for the call George
Campbell thanks for pressing through the
thanks for being with me in America
there he's struggling one last one we're
gonna get him a lossage thanks Austin
and crew for keeping us on the air and
you America for listening this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]